[Music]
hey welcome to every damn day we're
gonna play red light green light with
the hottest Halloween costume trends of
2018 but first to get you ready for some
nightmare if you'll watch this this of
course is a video from the doto of a
snake in the toilet there's a coming
trope the really scary thing is that
that is from right outside the studio
you're gonna say it was from you gotta
have a funny costume for Halloween or
else you're an idiot this is what people
are talking about according to the list
calm that's spelled ly st.com
throw up that first costume this is
Tonya Harding red light green light what
do you think green light Oh Todd yeah
yes and yeah you kind of look like
you're dressed up as Tonya Harding today
oh that's so crazy because I do want to
hit you Riverdale character any
character I love Riverdale I love it so
much
we're split Oh what's your costume being
hot being popular with teens adults
dressing up as sexy teens feels
dangerous yeah I think my wife and I are
gonna be arguing okay next blood this of
course is two characters from a movie
clueless oh we got a green light I want
to go as Alex Mac you but I want to go
when she's in her like metal I think if
I just covered myself in foil
we were like what are your baked potato
I'd be like no I'd be Alex Mack during
her transition when she's just like
gliding under stuff that's cool you'd be
people think you're trying to get half
off at Chipotle if you dress up as a
burrito yeah yeah it used to be free and
then yeah I'm gonna jump the half off it
might not be any more but you submit so
we would wrap ourselves in tin foil wait
in line what
clearly the best costume imagine going
to Chipotle and the deals expire and
you're fully dressed up as a burrito and
you really we're going and then we like
oh sweet your burrito I mean being like
no it's Alex Mac I want to pay full
price next up we've got a Wakanda
warrior any of you guys they can do what
Conda ally huh I googled black panther
costume on Google Images and the first
one was like clearly a white guy in the
black yeah well I need a final verdict
green light red light I think okay next
costume we've got a flamingo so what's
really great about this look is the pink
you can get just like by using blush or
eating nothing but shrimp for a year
either or I once I just want to share
this so bad I was at a show recently
performing and one of the other
stand-ups right before me did it a
terrible job was very mean to the
audience and then afterwards for his
free meal he had coffee and a shrimp
cocktail hot coffee and a shrimp
cocktail I was like you know what he's
going through something that guy sounds
like my soul mate what is it about 2018
that brought out flamingos as a possible
top costume I think everything now is
just such cultural appropriation people
are like Oh mango oh yeah any bird that
can like well Kim flamingos fly away
yeah right so flying away from any
situation flamingos can fly they can fly
nothing hi there
yeah that's true yes they're not like
bumping into airplanes but they can fly
alright next costume we've got is Edna
mode this is kind of a very specific one
this is from The Incredibles a quick
vote Edna mode I know this is me in 20
years you know it's not fun to see a
little future use I just don't want
everyone dressing up like me I like it
well this is awkward because I was gonna
vote yes because everyone likes like
mrs. incredible because they think she's
really hot but I think Edna's really hot
but if in 20 years you have Halloween
you will go trick-or-treating together
okay put it in your calendar hey Siri
remind me in twenty years from now to
call Natasha and ask her to oh my god
yeah it's added a date of twenty thirty
eight I'll give you a call in 20 years
that means we have to do this show for
that length of time so that this can
happen I assumed we were next on the
list we've got avidan Singh Queen Abba
is very popular worldwide I think it's
because it's a it's about white people
and white people are very popular around
they get to like dance a lot in this
film without like being made fun of yeah
because I think maybe that's part of it
this song someone dressed up like that
on the street you'd be like ah Abba so
yeah a scarf no it's it's just a white
person's costume I think this movie was
a response to Black Panther right is
white people black down oh yeah we got a
vote on it I love white people Black
Panther
all right next costume this is a classic
Halloween costume I think Frida Kahlo
why green I say green definitely I love
free to color but you can't not do the
unibrow
you can't this oh I didn't even notice
that one can I read it it
okay next costume this is closing out
cow and as you might notice that's not
just any cow that's from an internet
video this year I get why this one is on
the list for sure quick bow yes oh we
didn't have any you guys haven't seen
the video so why yes Jordan like that
video makes me so happy like when
watching it it's like the perfect
combination of like making me laugh and
then making me also like very horny and
specifically this is the doja cat video
okay so to see what makes Jordan horny
and laugh at the same time watch this so
this is a crappiest green screen it's
clearly meant to be a joke she's got the
French fries in her nose what are you
feeling right now
I don't know if she even used green
screen I think it's from the photobooth
camera where you have to duck out
there's nothing wrong with porn and this
is cool this is so not a costume and now
because this bitch has hot boobs and ass
it's cool it was not hot well I want to
give you a chance to redeem yourself by
right now proposing a better costume and
one of those Natasha when we start with
you yeah what is the ultimate 2018
costume the ultimate 2018 costume is
going as the screen painting gently get
the whole thing and then cut yourself
out so you're there with the background
cuz this year has been a night that is
our life now Jordan what do you got well
I have a picture of mine and so I think
the ultimate 2018 costume is Pete and
Ariana's relationship Oh
ghosts of the relationship so it's the
ghost of the relationship too soon
Geordi Pete oh they don't care about me
[Laughter]
also the sheet should be covered with
the tattoos if they now are getting
scribbled out and finally in Hana what
do you have for us Bradley Cooper from a
star is born so I can just wear full
jean and be fun clear liquor and pills
everywhere slurring my words people are
putting me to bed it's gonna be a
costume choice I'm not a mess in
constant the commitment to character and
you do that all year just be like I'm
Daniel day-lewis a Halloween Halloween
yeah I think that's the way to do it let
us know in the comments what you think
the ultimate 2018 Halloween costume
would be before we do something else I
think someone has a shadow from Natasha
what do you guys I have a shout out here
we go
this is a shout out from our sketch
series that you can see on every damn
sketch show so we released one Friday
called price slasher and dank game said
a knife daughter and to shift sons ha ha
ha that's a line from the sketch show
that you gotta see to know what is it
check it out every day I'm Sketchup and
I renew something different
[Music]
yeah The Shining is about a man that
kills his entire family but isn't it
really a story about how hard it is to
write books
[Music]
haha clean dicks what would be yours oh
I think the best costume of 2018 would
be a snake in a toilet look at it it's a
snake in a toilet and it wants to bite
your little bottom have you ever taken a
painful every day of my life yes
Wow this one really earned cuz it's just
a snake eating feels good then actually
the full video once he pulls it out you
see it's a two-headed snake that's
combining two internet things from 2018
alright this has been every damn day
please like comment subscribe and check
us out on Twitter to watch extra damn
day see you next time
[Music]